Dạng sáng quan ngày 3 mốt tháng 1 năm 2020, qua công tác có lỡ địa bàn,
công an phương an hai, tìm phố đàn nắng tính hành kiểm tra cân hộ cho推 trên đường
pháp đu, phương an hai, phát hiện và bác quả tăng bố đưa tượng có hành vi tổ chức
sự dụng trẻ phát chức mặt dưới, quân, thái thật đàn, sinh năm 2020,
chú phương an hai, vô hằng tụ chính, sinh năm 2020, chú phương thình khí, vóa văn chọc, sinh năm 2020,
chú phương mũ hành sơn, văn quyến tình thè anh, sinh năm 2020, chú phương linh chiều,
tính hình tích nhàng, cả muốn đối tượng đường dương tính với chức mặt tụi tổng hợp.
Qua đấu trên bàn đầu, cơ đối tượng hai nhận, khoảng 18,5 mốt năm 2020,
trong nước làm việc chương, trong này sình ý định sự dụng mặt tụi và dụi thè anh đến cân hộ của thỏa đàn để dụi
thè anh đồng ý và để gỡ trọng mô mặt tụi.
Đến khoảng 20,000 ngày, sau khi tăng ca, thè anh về nhà, lấy loang, để lấy vào mề trếu mào để cân hộ trên,
cùng thời điểm, trong đến phòng trọng của bản cái là tụi chình.
Tại đây, trong đến việc qua hạn xác hội đật 1,2 viên và tuy tưởng hợp giảng tuy góc
và một koi kết tâm in với ra ma về một chự động.
Sau khi mô được, trong dụi chình cùng sự dụng và được chiến đồng ý,
cả muốn đối tượng sau đó tụi tập tại con hộ của thỏa đàn tổ chức sự dụng chai phép chức
mà tuy thì bị công an phường kinh ra, phát hiện, bác quả thang.
Kinh công an phường an thải đang tiếp tục lấu trên làm só, cùng có hồ dựa để dụi cơ đối tượng theo đúng quy địa của phát lột.